[Musique]
des comptines en alsacien c'est
l'animation qui est proposé plusieurs
fois par mois au relais d'assistantes
maternelles de huningue salaï de la
communauté de communes de saint louis
benjamin intervient en direct auprès des
tout petits mais aussi dans les
maternelles les écoles primaires et les
centres aérés
objectif favoriser la connaissance et la
diffusion de la langue régionale
un cycle initié au bilinguisme dès le
plus jeune âge
l'animation qui est proposée au relais
d'assistantes maternelles à huningue est
une initiative de la commission
bilinguisme langue régionale de la
communauté d'agglomération dans le cadre
effectivement de sa politique de
promotion de la langue régionale et du
bilinguisme sur les communes de la
communauté d'agglomération
c'est vrai que nous constatons depuis un
certain nombre d'années une dégradation
lente et progressive du dialecte et il
nous semble extrêmement important ici
sur les cantons de saint louis au
carrefour j'irai de l'europe à la
croisée gérait de pays germanophones
qu'il était nécessaire de faire revivre
en fait notre patrimoine culturel en
reposant à la population donc un accès à
l'apprentissage un accès au bain
linguistique pour retrouver en fait
voilà une identité germanophone aux
enfants la multiplicité des langues est
toujours bénéfique
ça développe déjà les aires cérébrales
du langage même si ce n'est pas à haute
dose
le fait d'avoir plusieurs langues va
faciliter l'apprentissage du phénomène
linguistique lui même donc de la
maîtrise du langage
c'est pas vrai que en multipliant les
langues ont leur complique la vie un
enfant une plasticité cérébrale assez
impressionnante donc eux-mêmes
le fait qu'ils soient intéressés qu'ils
soient stimulés qu'ils arrivent même à
comprendre parfois mieux qu'un adulte et
a progressé beaucoup plus vite qu'un
adulte
rien que ce fait la montre qu' ils
peuvent en retirer un bénéfice direct
c'est vrai qu'on s'aperçoit que plus
l'apprentissage d'une langue et précoce
et plus elle facilite bien sur
l'apprentissage d'autres d'autres
langues en l'occurrence l'apprentissage
de l'allemand
les enfants qui ont passé par le cursus
bilingue beaucoup plus de facilité
ensuite apprendre une autre langue au
collège
[Musique]
m
dans ce canton près d'un habitant sur
deux travaillent de l'autre côté de la
frontière la question de l'apprentissage
de la langue allemande et centrale à
folgensbourg on l'a bien compris en 2003
dans ce village de 900 habitants on
ouvre une première classe bilingue avec
onze élèves
aujourd'hui ils sont 120 à l'instar de
cette classe ce1-ce2 à pratiquer au
quotidien à la langue de goethe
ils ont exactement le même programme que
les autres enfants mais seulement il
veut pratiquer à dans une autre langue
on fait de la grammaire ont fait de
l'orthographe on fait du vocabulaire
beaucoup de vocabulaire mais c'est
surtout basé sur le langage oral
donc on n'a rien essayé d'amener les
enfants à parler au maximum en allemand
il y en a qui vont oser sans problème et
il y en a qui vont répondre en français
quand je vais à leur poser des questions
en allemand ils seront pas forcément le
vocabulaire ou alors ils n'oseront pas
donc ils vont me répondre en français
mais c'est vrai que dans l'ensemble ils
disent ils aux facilement à folgensbourg
seul un tiers des élèves de l'école sont
inscrits en section monolingues
preuve du succès de l'initiative si
aujourd'hui le coeur des parents est
conquis pour en arriver là il a fallu
une solide volonté politique pour
soutenir les lourds investissements
réalisés pour l'école mais ici il s'agit
de préparer l'avenir on ne compte pas
hier une demande des parents
effectivement en 2002 avait qu une
double motivation il y avait la
motivation on va dire motivation
culturel on va dire l'alsace
je dirais était toujours germanophone
sous la forme de sa langue régionale
alsacien sous la forme du hors deutsch
donc une motivation culturelle et une
motivation de certains parents pour
faciliter l'apprentissage des langues à
leurs enfants et surtout trouver du
travail
dès l'école maternelle et on leur
apprend pas l'allemand leur enseigne en
allemand mais des choses toutes simples
de tous les jours aller se laver les
mains sortie rentrée et donc la
languette a pris comme un véhicule de
2,2 du langage mais on n'apprend pas la
grand-mère en premier on apprend comme
on apprend un enfant à parler les règles
de grammaire arrive par la suite en
classe élémentaire et plus tard alors
après l'école primaire et bien il
continue dans les collèges dans le
haut-rhin de mémoire sur 57 collèges
publics 33 en cursus bilingue il ya plus
d'un collège sur deux offres la
poursuite pour suivre en bilingue et je
crois que si on rajoute les collèges
privés ces 37 sur 61 donc pas de soucis
pour suivre au collège
le seul bémol c'est la difficulté de
recrutement des enseignants
s'il est acquis que pour les
travailleurs transfrontaliers la
pratique de la langue allemande est
indispensable dans ce secteur où les
frontières s'effacent peu à peu être
polyglotte devient de plus en plus utile
pour travailler sur le territoire
français aujourd'hui je crois qu'à peu
près enfin une grande majorité
d'entreprises un moment on évoquait 70%
des demandes d'emploi ici en france
exige ou chouette en fait la pratique de
l'allemand
il est vrai que un certain nombre
d'entreprises ici sont d'origine
étrangère soit d'origine allemande ou
suisse et
la plupart en fait des marchés ou des
des échanges
des entreprises locales se font
majoritairement avec les pays
germanophones
l'allemagne est notre premier partenaire
commercial
et aujourd'hui quand on maîtrise
l'allemand à diplôme égal c'est
évidemment un plus ce sont des
partenaires commerciaux avec qui on
échange on vend on achète et nos
artisans
ben je dirais peuvent travailler de
l'autre côté de la frontière tout comme
des gens notre quota frontières vienne
vienne chez nous d'ailleurs on parle de
frontières moi je vais reprendre le mot
de de jean ueberschlag qui disait que le
rein n'est plus du tout une fracture
entre les deux pays mais plutôt une
couture nous sommes plus que un seul et
même espace économique et humain donc
que l'on travaille en alsace ou en
allemagne ou en suisse
évidemment il faut parler l'allemand
pour ceux dont l'absence de maîtrise de
l'allemand représente un frein à
l'embauché des formations sont
accessibles dans le cadre d'une
recherche d'emploi ainsi que ce soit à
l'âge adulte où dès l'enfance il est
possible de s'initier à la pratique de
la langue germanique
si dans le canton de saint-louis ont
construit une réalité transnationale au
travers d'institutions d'infrastructures
et d'échangés économiques
cette réalité s'édifie aussi au niveau
culturel par la maîtrise de plusieurs
langues